George Hotes he made a name for himself
by unlocking Apple's iPhone George Hots
is one of the craziest hackers in modern
history doing criminal stuff's not
really worth it I want a uh super
intelligent AI girlfriend and I want
fully immersive virtual reality he's
been quietly building a company around
the promise of bringing self-driving
cars to the masses for the last 8 years
by the end of the decade we will let a
car drive across a City without a human
in it every other serious company in the
industry has billions of dollars to
throw at this problem but not George
Hots everyone wants to get rich quick
but they don't think about what the
potential downsides of this are he has
figured out how to make almost any car
drive itself for the price of a cell
phone I want a win self-driving car the
road to self-driving has been extremely
windy I wanted to see for myself how
much progress George has made on this
project over the last decade so I bought
a comma 3x and drove to San Diego to
meet up with him and see his operation
firsthand George Hots he was always
hacking things as a kid when he was just
5 years old he wrote his first computer
program on his dad's Apple 2 and by
fifth grade he was building his own
video game console using electronic
parts from Radio Shack he was even
featured on The Today Show after he
built a robot that could construct a 3D
map of the surrounding environment
George tell me a little bit about your
invention well I made a robot it like
Maps out rooms and stuff there's a
military application as well like they
could send it into a complex before the
military infiltrates it and then they
know exactly where to go in like know
where all the rooms are laid out George
made national news when he became the
first person to ever unlock an iPhone so
it could work with any carrier the
iPhone was Factory locked to AT&T but
George had a T-Mobile plan hi everyone
I'm
Gian this is the world's first unlocked
iPhone I went home and looked at my
T-Mobile SIM and put it in and it said
invalid SIM so ever since then I've been
trying to make my iPhone work with
T-Mobile he was just 17 years old at the
time the video of him explaining the
hack got 2 million views on YouTube and
this was back in 2006
Steve Jobs even commented on the
incident and Steve wnc sent George a
congratulatory email this was just the
beginning though George Hots AKA geohot
and he was the first person to jailbreak
an iPhone and last month he was the
first one to fully hack the PS3 console
he released this code online along with
the howto video and now finds himself
embroiled in a legal battle if companies
want to put these security measures on
these devices great good for them but if
we want to come in and we want to remove
these security measures so we can do
legal things with our devices and I
think we have every right to and I guess
that's my cause so they got into a
lawsuit and George responded in an
absolutely hilarious way he posted a
diss track calling them out for
attacking him yo it's geoh high and for
those that don't know I'm getting sued
by Sony it was a messy situation but
George had the support of the hacker
Community So eventually they settled the
lawsuit and he agreed not to hack any
more Sony
products 2015 was a big year for
artificial intelligence Deep Mind was
making big progress in key areas of
machine learning and don't forget this
was the year that open AI was founded
self-driving cars were starting to look
like a reality and every Automotive
executive started making ambitious
claims about how quickly they would be
rolling out full self-driving
capabilities Elon was one of the first
to really push the field forward at
Tesla a friend approached me and he's
like you want to meet with Elon Musk
he's looking for somebody to build a
vision system this is when they were
still on AP1 there were still using
mobile ey Elon back then was looking for
a replacement he brought me in and we
talked about a contract where I would
deliver something that meets mobile eye
level performance uh I would get paid
$12 million if I could deliver it
tomorrow and I would lose $1 million for
every month I didn't deliver but George
had a different idea of what the future
could look like he thought that Tesla
was essentially building the iPhone of
self-driving cars a closed system that
couldn't be modified by the owner of the
car George has always been focused on
empowering individuals to use technology
however they want unlocking the iPhone
let people use whatever carrier they
wanted and jailbreaking the PS3 let
people run any software they wanted
George wanted to build the Android of
self-driving and make autonomous cars
accessible to everyone he started comma
almost a decade ago now so I wanted to
see how his company Works firsthand so I
went to their headquarters and sat down
with George to discuss his company in
the future of
self-driving okay so right now we are
driving down to San Diego
in this I think it's like a 2020 Hyundai
Palisade I actually bought this car
because of George Hots um I was looking
for a new car and I went to his website
and found the car that was uh like high
most highly recommended by the comma
team so right now we're driving down to
San Diego to see him but we're using the
stock system so we're using the system
that comes with the Hyundai Palisade
it's just it has Lan keep assist so it's
keeping me in the lane and then it has
adaptive cruise control so it's kind of
cruising I need to turn up the speed a
little bit but
um but basically like it's pretty good
like I have my hands off the wheel I'm
very interested for our drive back when
we'll be using the comma because the
stock system is pretty good and I'm
wondering how much of a step up the
comma system
is this relaxing San Diego office is
where the company manufactures the comma
3x the product marks a shift from
developer kits to consumer product and
is way easier to set up especially if
you're non-technical the device has
cameras microphones GPS and Wi-Fi
everything you need to connect to the
car and take over steering and
acceleration so originally my plan was
okay I'm going to make autopilot I'm
going to sell the car manufacturers so I
didn't realize that the uh hard part of
that was not the make autopilot part the
hard part of that was the sell to the
car manufacturer's part and you look at
a company like mobile ey and you realize
that mobile ey spends more money on
Business Development than they do in R&D
that was kind of how I got the idea for
the business model I'm like well let's
just get this out to people and then now
we have a whole Army of people basically
working for us rooting for us to solve
self driving cars George's company
produces two main products the first is
the actual device which you can buy on
their website the 3x is really a
refinement to the three we use half the
parts it has half the components how do
you do the same thing with less Parts
yeah most of it's not even with
functionality reduction a lot of it's
just like we redesigned the power
architecture to use two rails instead of
four so we have two modes on the device
there chill mode and experimental mode
um if you're mostly doing highway
driving chill mode functions a lot more
like a traditional ACC experimental mode
though hands over the lateral control of
the car a longitudinal control of the
car the gas and the brakes completely to
the neural network so the lateral is
already completely controlled by the
neural network where your car decides to
go there's no Lanes roads anything like
that it is entirely just asking the
neural network where do I go the second
is the open source software that runs on
the device it's called open pilot and
because it's open source it can be
modified by anyone who wants to change
how the software works for free already
we have some people on our forums
talking about building them porting them
to the old Tesla that didn't have
autopilot that's the really great thing
about it being open those other cars
that we don't support people can
download our code and add support for
them this has allowed comma to scale
compatibility to hundreds of different
car models without actually needing to
buy every car that they integrate with I
love that with comma I have flipped the
whole you own the software thing on your
head so back in the iPhone I'm I'm the
guy you know okay jailbreak to iPhone
right and then you own the iPhone now
I'm on the other side of that I'm like
you're the company you own the software
I just flipped it I flipped it I'm on
the other side of that and you you know
that something I think you know you know
that something's a really good idea when
you're on both sides of it and still
think it's an awesome
idea I walked around the parking lot at
George's office to see the cars that
they used to test the product and then I
installed my comma 3 in my own car the
device is pretty simple it just takes in
streams of data from the outside world
through the cameras and sensors and then
outputs control signals through a port
under your steering wheel pretty much
every new car ships with a standard Port
these days so it's relatively easy to
add an aftermarket kit like the comma
when you want to add self-driving
features to a vehicle most of the
driving is done by the algorithm right
on this device yeah and it's it's deep
learning right it's deep learning it
uses the camera to try to predict what a
human would do in this situation and if
it predicts something reasonable it has
an internal test of reasonability if it
predicts something reasonable it takes
that path the Comm 3x is the first one
to ship with navigate an open pilot you
can type in a
destination and it's like a early era
FSD we have a video from last November
where it drove from downtown San Diego
to Taco Bell making turns stopping at
red lights stopping and stop signs
that's incredible yeah my my stock H uh
Hyundai Palisade does not do that after
we finished installing the comma we went
out to test it on the
road yeah yeah it is very chill and
you'll see also it's it can do quite a
bit more than highways so if you're on
like Country Roads yellow line it'll
move over for cars it'll do a
lot what you experienced was much more
the autopilot style features uh there
are FSD style features that you can
enable uh they will slowly trickle down
uh our business model does not involve
uh charging you more and more for the
software the software is free open pilot
and and that's the te technology that I
want to build I want to build technology
that like when you use it it's so simple
but what actually goes under the hood in
that device is unbelievably complex yeah
George is also working on new projects
He calls this one the body you can mount
a comma device to the top of the body
and then basically have a simple robot
at your disposal right now it's mostly a
development platform for people to hack
on but it's a cool extension of the core
technology Kama has built right now it
is literally just a comma 3 on a poll
two wheels it
balances keeps the comma 3 up there and
like there's so much you could do with
that already the Prototype is pretty
basic but you can imagine where this
goes over time this thing could just
confidently wander around a space and
take pictures and you know focus in on
things send you a text message when
someone's trying to break into your
building you know like like this could
already do so much of course but the
software's not there yet he's been on
Lex Freedman three times and clearly
thinks deeply about so many different
topics humanity is going to slowly hand
control over to the AI there'll be some
people who for various religious reasons
want to keep um the human line around so
do you do you not believe in like job
displacement from AI any of that stuff I
think the trends are just going to
continue as they were yeah I don't think
that I think that almost all Trends are
going to continue perfectly into AI
because I don't think there really is
anything called AI I think that AI has
been this gradual thing that's happened
over the last 70 years it's just called
the computer Revolution sure the whole
progression of software has been a
replacement of jobs there's no magic
when you hit AI I've had this like just
thought in my mind where it's like I
want the AI doomers to shut up at least
until I have a self-driving car the way
that I know that we're going to get
self-driving cars before an AI that
could potentially murder humanity is an
AI that could potentially murder
Humanity has to in way not just be
smarter than an individual human but
smarter than all Humanity yeah so in
order to get a self-driving car you just
need AI That's smarter than a single
human the biggest risk that we face as a
civilization is artificial intelligence
once there is
awareness people will be extremely
afraid I'm not sure it presents any
particular threat that previous weapons
have not it's just about how the people
are going to use the technology now if
Elon Musk is calling for an
international arms control regulation he
should look at history and see how well
that has worked I certainly think that
it's incredibly premature to talk about
any sort of government level AI
regulation he hasn't raised that much
Venture Capital but he still managed to
build something really impressive the
faster a company comes up the faster
that company will fall mhm I have a
staff that manufactures these devices
right George you could go to China you
could scale it up at what point does
your company own you explain to me
exactly what I would do with money right
these things are can money buy me fully
immersive VR can money buy me an AI
girlfriend it can't there's actually
very little things that money can buy
you I had a great time hanging out with
George at comm's headquarters after a
full day there it was time to drive back
to Los Angeles on the drive down I used
the stock system in my car but on the
way back I tried to let comma do all the
driving it's obviously hard to quantify
the Improvement exactly but I figured a
few hours of testing would give me a
solid feeling about about the value of
the product so we're halfway to Los
Angeles from San Diego and so
far it's been pretty good it did do an
an unexpected Lane change at one point
but it was fine mostly it's just really
nice to not need to wiggle the wheel and
not need to check in with the system
like it it watches me it does the driver
monitoring through the camera as long as
I'm looking at the road it knows that
I'm paying attention and I can just sit
back so I'm I'm much less worried about
hovering on the brake hovering on the
gas like just any other input for just
you know 10 minutes at a time I'm not
even really you know considering what's
going on with the system it's very very
mellow just in terms of actually making
this drive more enjoyable it's 100% more
more like easier than on the drive down
I've spent a few weeks now with the
comma 3x and can confidently say that I
love the product I don't own any stock
in Georgia's company and I don't get a
kickback if you go and buy one this is
just my honest opinion I wasn't
expecting the upgrade to be that
significant over the stock system but
it's much better in practice if you have
a compatible car it seems like a great
value for the price and it's fun to
support what George is working on Teslas
are still obviously great but for
certain people they won't make sense I
would personally just love to see Tesla
and SpaceX succeed because that's the
kind of world I want to live in you know
it comes back to the pie argument right
I'd rather Elon mosque have a much
bigger share of the pie than me as long
as the pie tastes awesome Cruz and weo
have also built amazing services but
those are pretty Limited at the moment
it's great to have a wild card in the
industry shipping a functional product
so quickly if you want to learn about
the history of Cru just check out this
video next thanks for watching